céine aide soignante puis infirmière
pendant 10 ans dans un grand hôpital
parisien est revenue à la Réunion pour
être plus proche de sa maman depuis 1 an
c'est à domicile et dans son pays natal
qu'elle a choisi de continuer à donner
des soins aux malades et au plus
nécessiteux en attendant de retrouver sa
famille rester
la décision c'est pas moi qui l'ai prise
la décision c'est mon mari parce que le
fait de à chaque fois de de voir ma mère
tout le temps rentrer à l'hôpital et
puis moi dans un état où je pouvais très
bien avoir un accident sur le
périphérique ne pas faire mon travail
convenablement quand j'étais en
réanimation donc c'est quand même une
grosse responsabilité donc je n'arrivais
pas à être concentré des fois je pensais
à ma mère il va arriver quelque chose
j'arrivais après une nuit de garde on
m'a m'appelit en me disant que ma maman
allait certainement pas passer la la
nuit ou la journée alors donc je
reprenais l'avion le soir pour arriver
ici à la Réunion ça a duré deux ou trois
fois comme ça et puis un beau jour je ne
pouvais plus il fallait qu'absolument
que je sois auprès de ça a été un décli
que je sois auprès de ma maman alors le
mur la
nuit est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
mieux que le malade soit dans dans sa
famille oui moi je je suis pour parce
que bon ben le le malade est dans sa
famille avec
bon son entourage ses habitudes euh les
visites de enfin il est dans son monde
il est il est pas dans une chambre
impersonnelle à l'hôpital B quand c'est
vraiment vraiment nécessaire il y a pas
tout ce qu'il faut tout le matériel
nécessaire c'est c'est mieux d'être à
l'hôpital mais quand c'est vraiment pour
euh juste un suivi
on peut presque plus rien faire c'est
mieux que la personne soit chez
elle
voilà en métropole on a tendance à à les
mettre dans des maisons des maisons
médicalisé avec un personnel hospitalier
avec un médecin qui passe de temps en
temps enfin il y en a ils ont des
médecins quand même sur place mais mais
moins chez la famille et tandis qu'ici à
la Réunion les gens sont plus chez eux
je pense qu'un certain moment ils
voulaaient créer euh des des locaux pour
justement éloigner les les personnes
âgées des de de leur famille mais je
pense qu'ici au niveau au niveau
mentalité c'est pas possible les gens
dès que dès que les parents sont sont
sont malades pour eux c'est à la maison
le grand-père la grand-mère ou même une
maman moi je rencontre des des gens très
jeunes hein qui sont handicapés mais qui
sont chez eux ils sont pas forcément
dans dans dans un service euh pour
handicaper ils sont dans leur maison ils
vaent à leurs occupations ils ont la
famille ils vivent même si ils arrivent
pas à parler ils sont là ils sont
présents ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
formidable alors petit chien
allez
voyz peux
rentrer allors Paul ù ah voilà on est là
là
d'accord j'ai des gens qui s'occupent
beaucoup de leur famille qui sont après
leur famille qui se
dévouent qui restent là qui qui s'occupe
de leurs parents qui savent très bien
que la maman va être là ou le papa va
être là pour un certain temps que après
demain il y aura plus rien donc ils font
tout pour mais il parle pas de d'hôpital
j'ai eu des gens aussi qui qui avaient
leur famille qui éta hospitalisé et qui
ont ramené leur famille chez eux pour
s'en occuper ça c'est c'est le côté
réunionné o les parents vraiment si si
la maman ou si le papa meurt à l'hôpital
c'est vraiment parce que ils étaient pas
prévenus où où il y avait un empêchement
ou c'était c'est arrivé trop vite comme
ça mais sinon en général les gens
ramènent leur famille chez eux et ça
c'est formidable c'est c'est c'est ça
que j'apprécie beaucoup moi ici il y a
des des gens qui sont capables de se
sacrifier moi Mo je connais des des des
jeunes filles euh comme la fille qu'on
vient de voir tout à l'heure s sacrifié
pour sa maman ça je trouve ça formidable
elle est là tous les jours elle n'a pas
de loisir c'està dire qu' qu'elle ne
voit
rien nous on est là on sert un peu de
pour lui amener tout tout ce qu'il y a à
l'extérieur quoi elle s'occupe de de de
sa maman tout le temps si par exemple
elle doit s'en sortir il faut qu'elle
emmène sa maman avec elle
euh donc moi je trouve ça formidable de
voir euh c'est c'està-dire à la Réunion
il y a des il y a il y a des extrêmes où
il y a des gens qui laissent carrément
le le leur famille dans un coin où il y
a d'autres personnes qui sont tous sont
vraiment vraiment après
autour après avoir travaillé à la
Réunion pendant 1 an en tant
qu'infirmière libérale est-ce que vous
serez capable de travailler à nouveau
dans un grand hôpital
parisien dans un grand hôpital non non
non je vous dis catégoriquement non je
ne pourrais pas je ne pourrais pas je
pourrais travailler un jour 2 jours euh
dans un service de réanimation je veux
pas dans un service autre hein euh ça
oui je ferai un jour 2 jours à la
rigueur une semaine mais dire que je
vais m'en aller quitter ici repartir
travailler dans un service de
réanimation me retrouver euh comme ça
non à la rigueurle je préfère dans ce
cas travailler dans un service d'urgence
sur le terrain
ici qu'est-ce que vous faites quand vous
avez un petit moment à vous mes moments
de loisir là j'en ai peu pour le moment
mais le peu de temps que j'ai bon c'est
la musique ça c'est mon pass-temp favori
c'est chanter d'ailleurs c'était mon
premier métier c'est ce que je voulais
faire bon ben la vie a pris le dessus il
fallait avoir un métier une famille et
tout donc j'ai tout laissé un peu de
côté mais maintenant je travaille ferme
j'aimerais bien quand même allier les
deux mes deux passions c'estàd ma
Vocation
c'est le métier d' infirmière et puis la
musique est-ce que vous composez oui
énormément c'estàd c'est bon
c'est tout ce que je ressens en général
je le mets sur papier et euh c'est par
des clics ça arrive comme ça j'écris
énormément des textes tout ce que je
vois j'ai mets en en chanson en texte
vous avez déj vous avez déjà eu
possibilité de chanter sur scène oui
éormément oui oui oui oui énormément
j'ai fait j'ai fait partie d'un
groupe il y a quelques années euh où les
quelques personnes avec qui je je
chantais ont percé et à Paris et après
j'ai fait partie toujours à Paris d'un
autre
groupe caverdien où on a fait quand même
pas mal de scènes aux États-Unis en
Hollande au Portugal dans Paris et après
donc j'étais avec un cadien et un de la
Guinée Bissao c'était quandme même bien
une très bonne expérience et après bon
j'ai fait quelques des clips
et sinon ici ici bon j'ai fait je suis
en train de entamer mes petites chansons
à moi je vais faire un petit tout petit
refrein vraiment pour maman mais j'ai
vraiment pas le cœur je vous le dis
hein
ser m dans
BR il est
là quand connait
pasom dessus la
terre façon n'importe comment on joue le
rôle de social s'il manque quelque chose
on est là on appelle s'il manque des
médicaments on va à la pharmacie on va
chercher les médicaments tout ça on fait
tout ce rôle là faut regarder tout faut
faut vraiment s'occuper du malade de la
Z quoi bon d'accord et la famille doit
aussi apporter une grande participation
c'est pour ça d'être bien avec la
famille de bien s'entendre avec la
famille de d'avoir vraiment le tout tout
ce ce cette collaboration là ça tout ça
ça quand tu t'en va ta ta moi j'ai j'ai
j'ai le cœur tranquille parce que je
sais que derrière je laisse un patient B
la famille va s'en occuper si je pas je
sais que le malade va rester comme ça et
je sais pas ce qui va se passer derrière
je suis pas tranquille moi je vais pas
rentrer chez moi avec l'esprit
tranquille je suis comme ça et
d'ailleurs on m'a déjà dit hein que
j'investissais trop que je jeux je
donnais trop de moi il fallait que
j'arrête ça que j'ai un jour c'est moi
qui vais payer de ma personne c'est pas
grave ça je m'en fiche m j'ai fa
alléger